nele du hast es ja schon ganz richtig
gesagt unserem bild live zuschauern und
auch den bild lesern ist die familie
hase natürlich in den letzten wochen
schon sehr bekannt geworden
sie haben mehrfach über ihren alltag in
der korona diese berichtet von allen
höhen und tiefen
jetzt sind wir bei ihnen die familie
hase beobachtet natürlich auch gespannt
immer die debatten im bundestag und die
entschlüsselt die natürlich dann auch
von der großen koalition beschlossen
werden
und heute sind nicht alle kinder da weil
zwei heute in der schule sind die
älteste tochter conny ist bei der arbeit
aber ein paar haben sich heute hier
hinter mir versammelt und natürlich auch
die der familienbonus die korona prämie
da schaut natürlich familie hase auch
gespannt darauf was die große koalition
heute beschließen wird denn laut
rechnung
ich habe auch gerade mit papa hase schon
gesprochen ist es so dass vier kinder
anspruch haben das wären also eine
einmalzahlung von 1200 euro für die
familie
das klingt natürlich erst einmal gut
aber inwieweit hilft es natürlich auch
der familie und diese frage gibt jetzt
gleich mal weiter an
rené haase corona premiere herr hase was
halten sie davon und inwieweit würde
ihnen diese prämie helfen
juli viel helfen nach den vielen wochen
die wir jetzt mit den kindern hier
eigentlich spaß hat mir eigentlich spaß
sind würde mir ermöglichen mit den
kindern schönen urlaub zu machen in den
sommerferien
und da wäre das eine große hilfe da ein
bisschen was gespart aber da könnte man
den kindern ermöglichen urlaub bieten
vorausgesetzt wäre natürlich dass die
regierung dazu entscheidet dass das
nicht auf hartz iv angerechnet wird bin
zwar berufstätig bekommen aber ergänzen
hartz4 und da wird jeder cent
angerechnet und ja also da müsste eine
vernünftige entscheidung getroffen wären
das dann als einmalzahlung außerhalb des
einkommens also nicht als einkommen
angerechnet wird
dann hätten wir wirklich einen schönen
urlaub
das ja bedeuten also wenn dieses dieter
krone bonus ausgeschüttet wird dass das
wären insgesamt wenn man auf alle
familien das in deutschland berechnet
würde würde die groko bis zu fünf
milliarden euro ausschütten auf einmal
ist dieses einmal würde ihnen dieses
einmal geld natürlich mein hilft es
ihnen natürlich aber wäre es nicht
vielleicht ein anderer stelle völlig
besser eingesetzt ihrer meinung
er hat jetzt immer stellen wird besser
eingesetzt wird gibt sicherlich menschen
denen es schlechter geht als mir
aber ich denke mal dass auch irgendwo
irgendwann auch mal wieder an den
steuerzahler gedacht werden muss ja
jahrelang eingezahlt hat ich war
jahrelang virus bauer habe viel steuern
gezahlt und wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
weit zurück kommen bekommen könnte wäre
dort vielleicht auch mal ganz nett
jetzt haben wir in den vergangenen
wochen
sie und ihre familie über den alltag in
der korona zeit berichtet vielleicht
können sie vielleicht ein zwei worte
ganz kurz sagen wie es ihnen momentan
geht mit ihrer familie im rosen sind
jetzt uns mut die anstrengung sind
natürlich enorm sagt italien an
verschiedenen tagen zu verschiedensten
uhrzeiten zur schule ist schon eine
logistische herausforderung aber
verstehen natürlich auch dass es aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht anders machbar
ist und wenn es dann immer wieder
schritt für schritt weiter geht dann
denke ich in richtung weg